-Well, guys, today is Friday
and that's usually when I
catch up with some
personal stuff.
I check my inbox, return emails,
and I write out
some thank you notes
and I was wondering
if I could write some tonight.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Is that okay?
James, can I get some thank you
note-writing music please?
[ Playing tender tune ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
-Jeez!
-He's in a good mood.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, "Plane,"
for being in the one flight this
week that didn't get canceled.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Appreciate it.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
Dr Pepper-flavored Peeps,
for, somehow, not being called
Dr Peepers.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Why not?
-It's right there.
-Why wouldn't you do it?
-Why would you not?
-What?
At least Dr. Pibb.
-Call me. These people have
to call me.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, people with Christmas
decorations still up...
[ Laughter ]
for introducing your neighbors
to the fun new game
Lazy, Out of Town, or Dead?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Not necessarily healthy.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Fresh laughter ]
Thank you, gas stoves,
for looking like
I'm staring down
at a Troll doll drum circle.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
Fruit by the Foot,
for being the red carpet
of fruit leather.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you, Scratch-Off
lottery tickets,
for pretty much being the only
reason people still use coins.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey, that's interesting.
-[ Indistinct ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, today,
for being Friday the 13th,
which means only one thing...
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
It's Patrick Dempsey's birthday!
[ Hip hop oompah music plays ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Clapping rhythmically ]
There you have it!
Those were my Thank You Notes.
When we come back,
we're playing Charades
with Lea Michele, Sadie Sink.
Stick around, everybody!
♪♪